wir wollen weiter schalten zu einem
mediziner der in den vergangenen stunden
dadurch aufmerksam geworden ist dass er
gesagt hat wir bräuchten eigentlich in
deutschland kompletten shutdown also
müssten einmal für ein ja vielleicht
zwei wochen komplett alles runter fahren
täters schließen schulen schließen und
so weiter warum herr us man ja erstmal
herzliche grüße nach berlin aus der
hauptkampflinie der versorgung und also
es ist einfach so wir müssen uns
entscheiden was wir machen wollen ja
wollen wir wollen den kosmetik machen
wir es richtig machen
ich weiß dass das natürlich auch normal
auswirkungen hat aber auch wirklich
gesellschaftlicher konsens sein muss was
ich damit meine ist wenn wir wirklich
den ausbruch verlangsamen wollen
effektiv verlangsamt wollen dann müssen
wir große menschenansammlungen
verhindern
das können wir nur indem wir zum
beispiel universitäten schließen schulen
schließen dann auch die größere fabriken
oder industrien auch in zwangspause
geben oder aber auch natürlich
veranstaltungen absagen
er ist ja schon der erste schritt
gemacht worden mit den veranstaltungen
absagen
also ich will nicht weiter harmlos nicht
das ist noch relativ zurückhaltend die
schweiz zum beispiel ist das schon ganz
anderen schritt gegangen die haben
gesagt grundsätzlich großveranstaltungen
sollten oder dürften in den nächsten
tagen und wochen nicht mehr stattfinden
wenn dort mehr als 1000 menschen
zusammenkommen davon sind wir weit
entfernt eigentlich noch und das sollten
wir zum beispiel überlegen ob wir nicht
da den schweizer vorbild nehmen und
sagen wirklich alle großveranstaltungen
bis ende märz ab zu sorgen
das heißt kitas schließen universitäten
schließen schwimmbäder schließen
das würde ja den alltag in deutschland
nicht nur erschweren sondern eigentlich
komplett lahmlegen
so müsste er wird den alltag deutlich
verlangsamen sagt was man so die sache
ist auch die das ist ja auch nur ein
gedankenspiel beim man kann natürlich
auch verschiedene schattierungen
darunter fahren aber es muss natürlich
auch ein gesellschaftlicher konsens sein
weil das kann man den politikern nicht
alleine auf werden weil schauen sie kurz
oder auch überlegt karneval abzusagen so
und ich selber bin überzeugter
rheinländer und damit auch karneval ist
und das ist natürlich schon eine ganz
harte entscheidung kann
abzusagen und man gleich im nachgang
hetzt man das vielleicht machen sollen
und müssen dann haben wir dann tut sie
mir ganz so weh wenn man im nachhinein
sagt man hätte es vielleicht absagen
können oder müssen ja genau richtig und
deswegen ist jetzt eine scheidung aber
die gefällt müssen den nächsten tagen
wirklich ich gehe mit dem virus um
mit der erkrankung wollt ihr wirklich
sag mal dass man bei spiel machen das
jetzt hier wir sind das die bälle die
kommt wollen wir durch die welle durch
mit allen konsequenzen
wir wollen wir versuchen der bälle vorne
weg gehen indem wir möglichst
menschenansammlungen und so weiter und
damit wirklich infektions rindern
ich weiß dass man sie haben sich von
berufs wegen oder auch privat eigentlich
zu hause mit allem eingedeckt womit man
sich schützen kann vielleicht können sie
ein bisschen was zeigen was sie da alles
bei sich gehortet haben und warum also
muss sagen er dienstlich also zum
beispiel hier die übliche gesichtsmaske
die leute kennen und so weiter das ist
nett hilft aber nicht vor die büros
sondern es ist er deswegen in china auch
üblich wenn man selber erkrankt ist
damit man die viren nicht noch weiter
die option weiter auf sagen das ist ja
ganz das ist ja ganz wichtig die dinger
sind ja schon total knapp in deutschland
das ist eigentlich ganz unnötig weil
anziehen müssten sie eigentlich tragen
müssten sie eigentlich vor allen dingen
die etwas mehr als 50 dm erkrankt sind
richtig aber jetzt müssen wir so sagen
ist es gleich gar nicht unnütz weil in
china und so weiter oder den asiatischen
ländern etwas rücksicht gemacht damit
ich die anderen mitmenschen nicht
anstecken
und das ist ja auch schon mal was und
das zweite das ist hier diese klassische
maske die wir haben
die hilft gegen ansteckung der jagd aber
auch eine bestimmte schutzklasse das
kann man ja unten sind also mindestens
ffp 2 oder ft3 aber das arbeiten unter
dieser maske ist auf dauer nicht lustig
das ist auch sehr anstrengend und da
müssen wir aufpassen
wir haben jetzt einen vorrat bekommen
noch oder organisiert wir haben über 50
masken apple damit neben personal damit
klarkommen
dann gibt es natürlich die profi masken
aber das problem ist meinte voran sagte
sie haben zwar die maske aber leider
nicht die passenden filter weil die
kommen noch lese oder sollen kommen wo
werden die produziert in china und das
ist ein zweites großes problem viele
produkte gerade die wir jetzt in der
fraktions vorsorge brauchen in china
produziert da sind die produktions
straßenlampen liegt und die brauchen das
natürlich selber chinesische regierung
hat zum beispiel ausfuhr exportverbot
kommen
also von daher wird es schwierig sich
die sache noch zu organisieren
das ist auch ein großes problem wir
werden wir hören ja dauernd was wir
machen sollten schutzmasken und so
weiter aber keiner sagt dann wo kriegt
er das her
deswegen ist zu überlegen das ist meine
überlegung ob nicht mehr eine zentrale
bevorratung gemacht wird damit überhaupt
genügend schutzmacht am abend das ist
interessant das ist ihr ratschlag also
die bundesregierung oder möglicherweise
die länder müssten zentrale vorräte an
solchen schutz ja wie soll man sagen ein
solcher schutzausrüstung schaffen
ja das auf alle fälle das haben wir ja
auch während des kalten kriegs gemacht
dass wir vor beratungen hatten und so
weiter angefangen über lebensmittel auch
mit medikamenten und jetzt kommt das
zweite ja wo werden die ganzen
medikamente den produziert ja du bist
auch in jena innehat ist eines der
zentren der pharmazeutischen industrie
in china
wir werden das problem wird nicht nur
der virus sein sondern und kriegen wir
in drei vier monaten unsere vita
medikamente her
und deswegen ist die herausforderung
oder auch die lehre die wir aus dieser
pandemie ziehen müssen wir müssen
vorbereitet sein für die nächste
bestimmt kommt und da wäre eine zentrale
bevorratung extrem wichtig und
medikamenten wie auch an ausrüstung
herzlichen dank dem notfallmediziner und
landarzt darf ich glaube ich sagen
thomas aßmann danke dass sie uns
zugeschaltet waren